j'ai pleuré je n'arrivais pas y croire
comme dans un conte il ya un côté
mystérieux se chasser cooking en 2014
il a traversé la france du sud au nord
soit 1000 km en 18 semaines pour
retrouver sa maîtresse
ce type d'odyssée incroyable et
médiatisé dès les années 80 en 1985 le
chat gaston passe dans le journal
télévisé
après avoir parcouru 100 113 km entre le
havre et la vendée pour re trouver
laurence st propriétaires partis en
vacances ensemble
en 1989 c'est autour de mick est une
petit yorkshire de défrayer la chronique
la chienne va retrouver ses maîtres
accidenté et hospitalisé pendant huit
jours me kate va errer à la recherche de
ses maîtres pour ce vétérinaire le doute
n'est pas permis
les chiens possèdent des capacités
biologiques hyper développé le chien a
cette particularité l'arrivée à repérer
une odeur particulière
c'est donc ce premier sens l'odorat qui
permet au chien de repérer même à grande
distance c'est m mais d'autres
chercheurs vont plus loin en 1996 rupert
sheldrake un biologiste anglais avance
une autre hypothèse une connexion relire
et l'animal à son maître pour prouver sa
théorie il réalise une expérience filmé
sur plusieurs semaines
le maître est éloigné du domicile où se
trouve le chien le moment du retour du
maître et décider de manière aléatoire
des caméras filment la réaction du chien
regardez en bas de l'image l'heure
tourne et lorsque pam smart décide de
rentrer chez elle son chien jti à
plusieurs kilomètres de là est quasiment
à la seconde près réagi se lève et
s'approche de la porte d'entrée
selon le biologiste le lien m animal
n'est ni biologique ni physiologique ce
qu'il reste cette expérience c'est une
relation invisible que la science n'a
pas encore expliqué appelez ça comme
vous voulez et télépathie liam psychique
sixième sens
moi je l'appelle un champ morphy sens et
multiplier ou sixième sens aucune
explication concrète ne fait vraiment
l'unanimité les
exploit de nos compagnons n'ont pas fini
de faire les gros titres des journaux
[Musique]